Last time we talked about how you should
live your life in light of the fact of
our year mortality.
How does the fact that we will die,
how should that affect the way that we
live? What we're going to turn to now?
Our final topic for the semester is the,
it's the flip side.
The fact of our mortality
raises the question as to
whether or not we should put
an end to our life.
Strictly speaking,
I suppose it's not the fact
that we're mortal per se.
It's one of those extra features of
death that I've discussed previously.
The variability of death and more
particularly still the fact that we can
control how long we live,
we faced the possibility of ending our
life earlier than it would end otherwise.
That's suicide of course.
And so our final topic is under
what circumstances, if any,
does suicide make sense under
is it inappropriate thing to do now?
It's a fairly widespread feature of our
culture that suicide is looked upon with
such a mixture of sort of disdain,
fear,
uh,
finding it sort of offensive that it's
very hard often to think clearly and
discuss the topic.
Clearly.
Most people think it's either that
you've got to be crazy to kill yourself.
The very fact that you are contemplating
suicide is evidence that you're crazy.
And if you're not crazy, then it
shows that you're a moral. Uh,
so suicide is clearly never, uh,
never right the right thing to do.
So what I want to propose is that we take
some time and look at the questions on
both sides, uh, with a fair bit of
care. And the very first thing to do,
I think in thinking about the topic of
suicide is to distinguish questions of
rationality from questions of morality
that is wanting us to take a look at
initially the question under
what circumstances, if ever,
would suicide be the rational thing to do?
And then later turned to
the question when if ever,
would suicide be a morally legitimate
or morally permissible or morally
acceptable thing to do in posing a this
distinction have obviously presupposing
that these questions can come apart
or at least they need to be examined
separately.
Questions of rationality on the one hand
and questions of morality on the other.
These are both questions about arts
as we might put it there evaluative
questions but at least most people are
inclined to think that we are drawing on
different evaluative standards when we
raised the ones that have questions as
opposed to when we raised
the other in many cases,
no doubt rationality and morality go
hand in hand and there are philosophical
views about the nature of rationality
and the nature of morality according to
which they always go hand in hand,
but many of us are inclined to
think that they can come apart.
Take for example, given the the
season of the year that it is,
consider doing your income taxes or
more particularly still cheating on your
income taxes.
The,
the rate at which income tax
forms get audited is very,
very slight and so,
and the fines tend to not be especially
egregious even if you do get caught.
So that from a rational point of view,
many of us might think it might well
be a rational decision to cheat,
not likely to get caught. Even if you do
get caught, how bad's the fine anyway.
But even if we were to agree
that it was rational to cheat,
most of us would then immediately go
watch or follow that remark up by pointing
out that doesn't at all mean that it's
morally acceptable to cheat on your
income tax.
There is a case perhaps where you're
morally required to do something that
you're not rationally required to do or
take a choice from the other point of
view.
There you are trying to decide between,
okay,
there you are trying to decide
between uh, your, uh, various, uh,
choices of college, uh,
and you've gotten into,
well Yale on the one hand and
perhaps some crummy school, you're,
you're second rate backup school,
uh,
on the other and you're trying
to decide what to do. There.
Well,
you might think to yourself morally,
I have no obligations here.
There's no particular obligation,
a moral requirement to go to the better
school rather than the worst school.
But for all that, it would be irrational
of me perhaps to go to the worst school.
So there's a case where there
is no moral requirement,
but there's a rational requirement.
Again,
we could debate the details
of the two examples,
but the point is just to show that in
principle, at least on the face of it,
these two questions can come apart.
Sometimes it's rationally acceptable
to do something, but it's a moral.
Sometimes it's morally acceptable to
do something, but it's irrational.
So I'm thinking about suicide.
We need to pose the two
questions one after the other.
So let's start with the question about
the rationality of suicide. When,
if ever is suicide a
rational decision to make.
Once again,
the first thing I want to do and thinking
about the rationality of suicide is to
distinguish two different issues
are two different questions.
First question is going
to be this. When, if ever,
would it be true that
you are better off dead?
Could it be the case that you know so
many of your life is going so badly that
you'd be better off dead?
Second question,
assuming that the answer to the first
question is under a such and such
circumstances, you would be better
off dead. We still have to ask,
could it ever be rational for you to
trust your judgment that this is one of
those cases in you're better off dead?
Could it ever be rational for you
to kill yourself? Conceivably,
the answer to the second might be no.
All right,
so the question was this.
It's conceivable that you might
have the thought like the following
in those circumstances in which life has
gotten so horrible that you'd be better
off dead.
He can't think clearly,
and the very fact that you can't think
clearly would entail that you shouldn't
trust your judgment that you
are in one of those cases.
Whether that's a good
argument or not or not.
It's something we'll
have to turn to later.
But it's because of the possibility
of that argument that I wanted to
distinguish the initial question.
Could it be true that you're better
off dead from the secondary question,
even if it could be true
that you're better off dead,
could it ever be a reasonable or
rational decision for you to believe that
you're in one of those situations?
Unless we've got the two things in place,
it doesn't seem likely that it's ever
going to be rational to commit suicide.
So the very first topic we have to look
at is could it ever be true that you'd
be better off dead and immediately
there's a kind of logical worry that may
occur to some of you certainly has
been raised by various philosophers and
that's to say that the very judgment,
the very claim that Jones
would be better off dead,
can't make any sense on
the assumption that look,
in order to make comparisons better off,
worse off here he is in
such and such a situation,
he'd be better off in
that other situation.
You've got to be able to talk about on
the one hand what condition or state the
person is before and what condition or
state the person would be in afterwards
if they were to make that choice.
Call this the two state requirement.
Normally when we make judgements about
whether something would leave you better
off or worse off,
we satisfy the two state requirement.
You're trying to decide whether or
not to lose some weight and you think,
well, here's how well are off.
I am now being overweight.
Here's how well off I would be
later if I were to lose that weight.
I can compare the two states, say the
second states better than the first state.
That's what makes it true that I'd be
better off trying to decide whether or not
to marry the person or or break up with
the person or or pick this career or
change careers.
You've got the state you're in and you
compare it to the state you wouldn't be
in. You compare the two states.
That's what allows us to say, yeah,
I'd be better off or no,
I'd be worse off.
But when we're talking about
cases of suicide cases where,
well, here I am now the the before
state requirements in place.
But
if we contrast that with
the after state requirement,
well that part's not met right?
When you on the assumption that death
is the end that you won't exist.
Non-Existence isn't a
state that you will be in.
It's not a condition of
you because you know,
states and conditions
presupposes existence. We
can talk about are you happy,
are you sad, are you
bored, are you excited?
All those things presuppose
you're just even,
are you sleeping is a state or condition
you can be in because you exist.
But if I kill myself,
I won't exist.
There is no second state to compare.
So how can we possibly
say the objection goes,
how could we possibly say
that I'd be better off dead?
That seems to presuppose that there is
a second state that we can compare to my
actual state.
Since there isn't one the judgment,
I'd be better off dead,
can't even get off the ground and it it,
it's got a logical mistake
built right into it.
Well,
that's the objection and as I say,
there are a number of
philosophers who are drawn to it.
Maybe some of you are drawn to it as well.
It seems to me that it's mistaken.
Consider what we wanted to say.
When we talked about
the deprivation account,
the central account of
what's bad about death.
For most of us dying would be bad because
it would deprive us of the good things
in life that we would get
if only we didn't die.
That seemed like a natural thing to say.
It seems like an appropriate thing to say.
Of course we might ask if we believe
in the two state requirement,
how could we have said that after all
given the two state requirement to say
that death is bad for me,
I'd be better off staying alive if we
believe in the two state requirement,
we've got to say, oh, so had I died,
I would have been in some state that I
could compare to my current state and say
that it's worse.
But of course death isn't a state.
So the two state requirements
not met. Well, they might say,
this doesn't give us some pause if
the two state requirement, you know,
it'd be one thing if, if all of the two
state requirements said was, you know,
we can't ever say it'd be better off dead,
but it turns out the two
state requirements got
more implications in that.
It's got the implication that you can't
even say you're better off staying alive
and that's very,
very hard to believe.
Imagine that you've got some happy person,
some incredibly happy person
with old wonderful life.
It filled with whatever goods you
think are worth having in life,
love and accomplishment and
knowledge and whatever it is.
He's walking across the street and
he's about to get hit by a truck.
And so at some risk to yourself,
you leap into the way
pushing him out of the way,
saving his wife and happily
you don't get hurt either.
Okay?
He looks up and realizes he was
this close from death and he says,
thank you,
thank you for saving my life.
And now what you have to say is I'm
spread you rather confused because to say
thank you for my saving your life is to
presuppose I've benefited you in some
way.
To presuppose I benefited you in
some way is to assume that you're,
it's a good thing that your
life has continued, but you see,
given the two state requirement,
we can't say it's a good thing that
your life continued because to sue state
requirement says we can only make that
kind of remark when there's a before
state and an after state and the after
state would have been nonexistent.
So you see,
you're really rather philosophically
confused in thinking that I've done you
some sort of favor by saving your life.
I can't take that argument seriously.
It seems to me that,
and I hope that none of you
would take it seriously either.
Of course you are doing somebody
a favor when you save their life,
given the assumption that their life has
been ad would continue to be wonderful
and what that shows is not that.
So nonexistence really is a kind of
spooky super thin state or condition.
No, of course it isn't. Not
Existence is not existence.
It's no kind of condition or state at all.
What it shows is the two state
requirement isn't a genuine requirement.
I'm these sorts of evaluations.
We don't have to say that if you had
died when your toe pointed a person whose
life you said,
we don't have to say that had you died,
you would have been in
some inferior state.
We simply have to say the life you would
have had had I saved you and indeed
we'll have given that I have
saved you is a great life
since it's good to lose.
It would be bad since
losing it would be bad.
Saving it for you is benefiting you.
It's doing you a favor.
Okay.
To state requirements says otherwise
the two state requirements got to go,
but having gotten rid of it,
we can say the same thing in principle.
On the other side,
I imagine there was somebody
whose life was horrible,
full of pain and suffering and misery.
Now whether there could be such a person,
again, that's a question
we'll turn to in a second.
But if there were such a person,
then we can say for their life
to continue isn't good for them.
It's bad for them.
Their life is full of misery and suffering
and frustration and disappointment
and the more and more of that,
the worst and worst of life is to lead
a life of a hundred years where every
moment is torture and pain is worse than
a life of 30 years where every moment
is torture and pain.
So if you had such a person for
their life to go longer would be bad,
in which case for their life to be
going shorter would be better for them.
And that's all we mean when we
say they'd be better off dead.
Not that there's some spooky,
super thin and hard to describe condition
that they'd be in if they were dead.
But simply we look back at
the two possible lines they
could have just with the,
with the person whose life we saved,
the first person we, we compare the,
the great life that lasts a hundred years
versus the great life that only lasts
20 years because you didn't
save their life. We say, ah,
the life of a hundred years better life.
And so saving their life
is a good thing for them.
Similarly,
we compare the lives of misery,
the long life versus the short
life of misery. And we say, ah,
the long life of misery is a worse life
to have than the short life of misery.
And that being the case, we simply
can say you'd be better off dead,
not that you'd be in some condition.
That's a good one.
It's simply you'd avoid this condition,
which is a bad one.
And if a two state
requirement says otherwise,
so much the worse for the two
state requirement. All right,
so this was by way of the,
the logical worry that we can't even
get off the ground in talking about the
possibility that you'd be better off dead.
I think if we believed in the two state
requirement, maybe we'd have to say that,
but the cost of accepting the two state
requirement is so implausible that the
person's dying of a heart attack
and you perform CPR, right?
Instead of saying thank you,
they say, Oh, you know, I'm,
no really no better off than
I would have been if I died.
Even though I'm having a wonderful
life to stem requirements,
just so implausible, we should let it
go. Now, having done that, of course,
doesn't yet tell us that it could in fact
be the case that somebody's life could
be so bad that they'd be better off dead.
That the existence that they've got
is worse than not existing at all.
All we've done so far
is leave open the door,
open the door to a possibility
of saying that coherently.
But that doesn't mean it's true. Whether
or not they're couldn't be such lives.
Depends on your view about what's
the correct account of wellbeing.
What is it that goes into making
somebody's life worthwhile?
Now, as we've seen previously,
this is a controversial topic.
People disagree about the ingredients
of the best kind of life and because of
these differences,
you're going to get
philosophical differences of
opinion with regard to whether
or not a life could be so bad,
that'd be better for it to come to an end.
I'm not going to try to rehearse all the
possible theories there are or for that
matter, even all the theories that
we've talked about previously.
But to give you an illustration
of how it couldn't be true,
imagine go back to our
simplest theory of wellbeing.
Hedonism according to which your quality
of life is a matter of adding up all
the pleasure and subtracting all the
pain and we need to take into account how
long the pleasures and the pains last
and how intense the pleasures and the
pains are.
But still we,
we add up this the total amount of
pleasure at if the total amount of pain,
subtract the pain from the pleasure and
look to see what our grand total is.
If it's positive, your life's worth
living and the greater the number,
the greater the positive number,
the more your life is worth living.
If it's negative though,
if your life is filled with pain and
suffering or at least so much pain and
suffering that it outweighs
whatever pleasures you may
have in your life so that
your balance is a negative one,
then your life's not worth living
to having that go longer and longer.
It's just more and more negative balance.
That's a life that's bad for you to have
and you'd be better off not having it.
You'd be better off having your life
come to an end. You'd be better off dead.
And of course, the more and more
negative the grand total is,
the worse your life is.
And so the more it's true that
you'd be better off dead. Well,
that's what he knows him says.
If we're not hitting this,
and of course previously I've argued
that we shouldn't be hardness,
then we need a more complicated theory
of the good we need to throw in other
things.
Perhaps certain external goods that just
a matter of getting the insides right,
the pleasure and the pain
and the other mental states.
They're very facts about your objective
hookup with the rest of the world.
Are you really climbing Mount Everest?
Are you really accomplishing things?
Do people really love you
and so forth and so on.
Whatever your list is of
those other objective goods,
well you'll probably also want to have
a list of other objective bads besides
pain and but still the same basic
idea is going to be in place.
We're going to water somehow add up
all of the various objective goods,
add up all the various objective bads and
see where the balance lies to the good
outweigh the bad. If the goods
out weigh the bad, that's great.
Your life's worth living,
but if the bad outweigh the good,
then your life is not worth
living or not worth continuing.
Now,
as we've noted before,
there are philosophical theories
which go on to claim, pessimists,
various versions of pessimistic
views which say for everybody in all
circumstances,
life is so bad that
they'd be better off dead.
Life's so full of suffering and misery
that whatever pleasures there are and
other goods they may be in the life they
get outweighed by the objective bads.
There are philosophical views like that,
but I suppose the common sense view is,
well,
even if some lives may be so bad
that the person's better off dead.
That's not true of all lives.
It depends on the facts of the case,
so let's focus on that possibility.
Of course.
Even here we still have to
return to another issue that
we've considered before.
Namely is life itself worth having is
the very fact that you're alive itself a
good thing?
These are the valuable container theories
which I've previously contrasted with
the neutral container theories.
You'll recall that according
to the neutral container
theories in thinking about
the quality of someone's life,
you just look at the contents.
Life itself is only a container,
good or bad,
depending on what it's filled up with,
but opposed to the neutral
container theories.
We had valuable container theories which
say the very fact that you're alive add
some positive value above and beyond
whatever's going on in your life.
Now, even the valuable
container theories came in.
Different versions that were more
modest versions were in principle,
the positive value of being
alive could be outweighed.
If the contents got bad enough and we
contrast that with fantastic container
theories according to which
being alive is so valuable,
then it doesn't matter
how bad the contents get.
The grand total is always a positive one.
Now look,
if you accept a fantastic
container theory,
then pretty clearly it's never true
that somebody could be better off dead
because no matter how
bad the contents get,
okay,
the fact that they're alive
per say is so valuable,
it outweighs that subtotal
giving us a positive grand total.
Okay,
so pretty clearly from the perspective
of fantastic container theories,
suicide will never be rational because
it's never true that you're better off
dead because it's never true that your
life overall taking everything that's
relevant into consideration
gives us a negative.
Yeah.
Question.
What's
intrinsically good
question was on the
fantastic container theories.
What's so incredible about life itself?
Are we saying it's intrinsically valuable
and yes, the answer is precisely right.
The fans of the valuable container
theories are saying being alive itself is
valuable. You may recall that I previously
said, although people talk that way,
they probably don't actually mean
it, right? If you talk to them, okay,
you can be alive as a blade of
grass, they wouldn't say, oh,
wouldn't that be wonderful?
That's worth having most fans of the claim
that being alive per say is valuable.
Don't really mean life per se.
They mean something more
like life as a person,
you know,
being the kind of entity who can think
and plan even if the it what your,
your plans go wrong.
At least you were a person
able to experience things,
know things and so forth.
Of course,
if that's the reason for accepting the
fantastic container theory that we might
wonder,
what should we say about those cases where
the p functioning has decayed and the
person is no longer able
to continue as a person,
but perhaps can still
feel pain in that case?
Perhaps life could cease to be worth
living though you know whether or not we
should describe it in that way.
Also too depends on these complicated
issues that we've discussed previously
about would that still be you?
Would you still exist?
Would you still be alive
under those circumstances?
So the basic idea behind
valuable container theories
is that life or the life of
a person or something like that has
intrinsic value above and beyond the
question of what's going
on within your life.
If we accept the fantastic
container theory,
maybe nobody's life is ever so bad,
grand total because that's so that
suicide would be the rational thing to do
because the value of life per se, so
incredible that it outweighs the contents,
it has to outweigh the contents.
That's, that's a philosophical view.
At the opposite end of the pessimists.
The pessimists said,
as a matter of philosophical reflection,
we can see that everybody's
life is worse than nothing.
The fantastic container fans are saying,
it's a matter of philosophical reflection.
We can see that everybody's
life is better than nothing.
Most of us, I imagine, find
ourselves somewhere in between.
Either we believe in the neutral container
theory and think it's a contingent
matter whether the contents
are sufficiently good or bad,
or we may accept the modest version of
the valuable container theory and that
theory. Of course, life
has some intrinsic value,
but it's got a finite intrinsic value.
And in principle,
even that could be outweighed if the
contents get bad enough. And so again,
it will be an empirical question.
We have to take a look and see.
In which cases do the
contents get bad enough?
Now, I guess I'm one of
these people in the middle.
I'm inclined to think it's not true that
everybody's life is worse than nothing.
Nor is it true that everybody's
life is better than nothing.
It varies from person to person and
indeed not just since we're thinking about
suicide, we're not talking
about their life as a whole,
but really what does life
promise from here on out?
Sadly to enough sad to say,
it seems to me there are
cases and probably most of
us are familiar with cases
where the correct
description given the your,
your favorite theory of wellbeing is
going to be that for this person here on
out what life has to offer is
sufficiently bad so that the contents are
sufficiently negative as to outweigh
whatever value life itself might have.
We could imagine somebody in the terminal
stages of some illness where their
cancer perhaps is causing them a great
deal of pain and the pain is so bad that
they can't really do
much of anything else.
It's not as though they can
continue working on their,
their novel or continue talking with the
members of their family because they're
just distracted by the pain and wishing
it would come to an end horribly enough
in many degenerative diseases leave the
person less and less capable of doing
the things that give life value.
And the very realization that you're
in that situation and no longer able to
spend time doing things or
hanging out with your family or,
or talking with them or whatever it is,
may itself be a source of
more frustration and pain.
There are medical conditions were horribly
enough infants get born where they're
just in, in, in continual pain and
they never develop cognitively.
Their brain doesn't develop and then
they die and you look at these lives and
you say,
these are lives.
I want to say these are lies
that were not worth having.
These children would have been better
off never having been born at all.
Certainly not any kind of favor
for them to continue their lives.
Well,
let's focus on some case like the the
terminal patient persons got a disease.
At least that would be a nice easy
example. Not Easy to live through,
but easy philosophically easy example to
think about some terminally ill patient
whose disease is getting worse and worse
and so there are fewer and fewer of the
good things in life that the
future holds for them. Instead,
what the future holds
is more and more pain,
suffering incapacity and frustration.
When it gets bad enough,
it seems to me in some of those cases,
the person can correctly say,
oh,
we at least can correctly say of them.
They'd be better off dead.
All right,
let me try to draw some examples.
Again,
we're bracketing the question,
can the person think clearly about
their case? That'll come later.
Let's just try to talk about
when would suicide make sense,
when would it be sort of a rational
thing to do to end your life.
Couple of different cases
going to draw graphs.
ELEKTA x axis represent time
and
the y axis represents how good
or bad your life is at that time.
For those of us who are fans of
the neutral container theory,
the thing to say is this represents the
overall goodness of your contents or the
overall badness of your contents. The
higher up, the better the contents,
the lower down,
the worst.
The contents for those who are fans
of the modest container theory,
this represents the grand balance,
so it's contents plus the extra
bit you get from being alive.
But of course if you're a fan
of the modest container theory,
then even if the contents are negative,
the grand belts might still be positive.
But this represents the
overall bottom line,
whether you accept the neutral container
theory or the modest container theory.
So here's an example of
what a life look like.
It's going along pretty well and then
things get worse and things sort of
deteriorate.
And let's suppose
this point represents when you would
die of natural causes, natural death.
So towards the end lives not as great as
it was when you were young and vigorous
and healthy and adults, all sorts of
opportunities and accomplishments,
but still till the very end,
it stays positive.
Well,
if that's what your life line
would look like pretty clearly,
suicide doesn't ever make any sense.
In particular. You wouldn't
want to say, oh look,
here's the place where I
should kill myself because
here's where things start to
get worse. Yes, things are
beginning to get worse,
but they never get so bad
that you're better off dead.
So suicide wouldn't make any sense at all
for suicide to make sense.
It's gotta be the case that your
life takes a turn for the worse,
not just any old turn for the worst,
but it turns so much for the worse
that for some chunk of your life,
okay,
your life has worse than non
existence. The zero line, the x axis.
All right. I imagine that's
what's happened. You know
here you are, you're healthy,
you're vigorous,
you're accomplishing things,
but you've got some degenerative disease
that's going to make things worse and
worse.
Here's the period which is getting worse
and then after a while your existence
is going to be worse than nothing.
Here we can at least broach the
question in an intelligible way.
Might suicide makes sense.
Suppose this is the point
where the downturn begins.
Should you kill yourself at that stage?
No,
because after all,
even though there's a downturn,
things are getting worse. There's still
going to be another period of life,
another chunk of whatever it is, year,
five years, six months, whatever it is,
where although life isn't as
good as it had been before,
it's still better than nothing.
Yeah.
Killing yourself at this earlier
moment is we might say premature.
It's throwing away a chunk of life
that would still be worth having.
It's not the right thing to do.
It doesn't make sense. Rationally,
well, if not that moment.
What about this moment?
Here's the precise point at which your
life is becoming worse than nothing.
For some initial stretch of that,
it won't be very much worse than nothing,
but still overall it's a negative.
Up to that moment your life was worth
living from that moment on your life is
worse than nothing.
If you've got complete control
over when to kill yourself,
well that would be the time to do it.
Suppose you don't have complete control.
I mean it's straight forward
enough to say if you've,
if your life is going to become worse
than nothing and you have complete control
over when you kill yourself,
seems pretty plausible to say.
The precise moment at which suicide would
become rational would be exactly that
moment at which your life became
not worth having,
but you might not have
that kind of control.
Suppose that what you've got is a
degenerative disease that is going to
progressively strip.
You have the ability to control your body.
So your mind works for a much longer time.
And so for a period of time you're,
you're basically stuck in your hospital
bed being fed by somebody else,
but perhaps you're able to listen to
your family, talk about things, uh,
have books read to you.
Maybe you can engage in conversation,
even though you can't use
your arms and so forth,
your life is still worth living.
But the time's gonna come when
your life won't be worth living.
And at that point,
you'll no longer have the ability to
kill yourself because you won't have
control over your body.
Yeah,
raises the question,
I'm sure you can all see at this point,
the question I'm suicide also turns into
or comes up against the question about
euthanasia or mercy killing.
Under what circumstances is it ever
rational to ask somebody else to kill you?
Under what circumstances, if ever, is it
morally legitimate to kill somebody else?
But let's continue to focus
on the case of suicide.
Suppose you will live in a society which
is so unenlightened as to have ruled
out euthanasia.
In fact,
you live in our society and so what
we don't allow is the possibility of
somebody else coming along and
killing you when the time comes.
So you know that time is going to come
at which you'd be better off dead,
but once you're there, once you're
here, it's too late. You can't do it.
You won't have the ability
to kill yourself and nobody
else will be able to do
it for you.
In that case,
killing yourself earlier
might still make sense.
Take this earlier point.
For example
here,
if you kill yourself now you're throwing
away some life that's worth living,
but if this is the last moment at
which you're going to be able to kill
yourself,
it might still make sense rationally
because your choice is not ended here or
ended there.
We're assuming you don't
have the possibility of
ending it here at the precise
moment at which life became
no longer worth having.
Your choice instead is really just this
ended here and throw away this whole
last bit or not.
And it and then continue until
you die from the disease.
So your question is only,
what do I think about the value
of this last bit on the whole,
it's got a good part
and it's got a bad part.
Is it better to have the good part and
the bad part or better to have none of
it? And the answer of course is, well,
if the bad part is going
to continue long enough,
it's better to have none of it.
The bad outweighs the good so that the
rational thing to do would be to decide
to end your life then when you still can,
rather than condemn yourself to
the long final stretch of life,
not worth living.
Well,
what if the last time that you could
actually control it was way back here,
but for whatever reason it is
here,
you've got access to the means of killing
yourself and you won't have access
later.
Your life still gone.
It'd be great for a very long time and
then inevitably it will be bad for a
period of time. But at least if I've drawn
it right, if not, we can shorten this.
And I'm supposed to death would come here.
Here's a case where if
you don't kill yourself,
now you're condemning yourself
to the whole rest of the story.
But it might say,
alright,
although admittedly the end of
the story is going to be negative.
The only way to avoid that negative last
part is to throw away this very long,
great initial part that
doesn't make sense.
Although your life and now still going
to be a mixture of good and bad and you
wish thorough way to end it here,
you don't have that choice.
It's throw away the good and the bad
or keep them both. And in this story,
obviously enough,
the good is enough to outweigh the bad,
so suicide doesn't make
sense in that situation.
Here's a rather different,
wait, the story might go,
suppose
your life's going along really great
and it takes a turn for the worse,
but then it's going to get better.
Told ends here.
Death by natural causes.
Good suicide.
Make sense here?
Yeah.
Does it make sense to say,
look,
I'm going to kill myself in order
to avoid the downturn or indeed,
even if there were,
the recovery wasn't so long a recovery.
Good suicide make sense here because
you're about to take this big dip down and
be condemned to most of the rest of your
life being significantly worse than it
was before.
No,
suicide doesn't make sense in this
situation because even though what you're
going to have during this period is a
life worse than the life you had before.
The life you've got here
is still above the x axis.
It's still a life worth living.
This point I think is probably crucial
enough that it's worth taking a moment to
reflect on the fact that your life
is less good than it had been.
Less good than indeed maybe all the lives
around you are having all the people
around you are having lives that are
better than yours still doesn't mean that
your life is so bad that
you're better off dead.
It's easy to lose sight of that.
Right here we are sliding down and all
we see is sort of the fact that we're
moving down. It's natural to
get caught up in the thought,
I'm better off dead,
but it's a mistake.
You're not better off dead.
This situation I suppose is probably,
I always worry when I spent,
when I end this class teach talking
about suicide because look, you know,
what's the major cause of death
among teenagers? Well, it's suicide.
That's not really saw that
surprising because you know,
teenagers are pretty healthy
as people go, ah, and so the
[inaudible] get killed by an accident or
you're going to kill by doing it to do
yourself.
The kind of mistake that I think leads
most teenagers into killing themselves is
something like this. No, they've
broken up with their girlfriend.
They flunked out of school.
They didn't get into medical school
or law school or what have you,
and they think to themselves, ah, from
here on out, my life's not worth living.
The answer is no.
That's actually as an objective matter,
probably not the case.
Even if your life would be less worth
living then you had hoped it would be.
It's still better than nothing,
of course. And the typical case,
I suppose what it really
looks like is this
small dip thing continues wonderfully,
but you sight of all the good stuff yet
to come while you're in the middle of
the dip.
So although I'm taking time
now to talk about the question,
under what circumstances might
suicide be a rationally justified one,
I should hasten to add the remark that
I'm fairly confident that for nobody in
this class would suicide,
in fact be a rational decision.
That doesn't mean it couldn't turn out
to be a rational decision later in your
life,
but that very likely,
overwhelmingly likely is not one now.
Well, a couple of other cases that
I still want to have us consider it,
but I think that's
probably enough for today.
So we'll take it up there next time.